are you guys big news out of washington
dc today so the administration came out
and they are forgiving per person ten
thousand dollars of student loans if you
make a hundred and twenty five thousand
dollars or less so first and foremost we
want you debt-free we want you debt-free
so we're happy if you got your debt
but a lot of people aren't happy a lot
of people are very angry because they
paid off their student loans and what do
they get oh they get the burden of
having paid off these other people's
student loans so this is a political
move the biden administration is doing
this to
kind of get your attention and make you
love them because the midterms are
coming up and this is an economically
failed
presidency horrible and he's out of
control and it's a mess so people are
very angry and people are very happy
today and we're a little of both over
here 300 though 300 billion dollars you
guys on the taxpayers now so remember if
you want to fix your life who fixes
their life ah we fix our own lives we
don't wait for washington to fix our
lives fix your life so get become debt
free you guys asap